أنا أريد فقط أن أكرر أه أو أكرر
ما قاله
أه ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان
اليوم قال إننا
في حاجة ماسة إلى أه لتوحيد
الجهود للنهوض بمنطقتنا
ومواجهة التحديات
التي تحيط بنا ومضى يقول
خاصة مع التهديدات  يطرحه
البرنامج النووي للنظام الإيراني ، برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية
ومشاريعه التخريبية المدمرة
التي
يتبناها وكلاء إيران الإرهابيون والطائفيون ،
هذه وجهة
نظر تشاركها سيدي.
دول المسيح هناك
قلق حقيقي من البرنامج النووي
هناك قلق حقيقي من برنامج الصواريخ
وهناك قلق حقيقي من
السياسة الإقليمية الإيرانية أعتقد أن هذه
وجهة نظر معلنة ولكنك تعلم في نفس الوقت
أعتقد أن دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي  أنضج في الدعوة إلى أه
حلول سياسية لهذه
القضايا وأعتقد أن هذا شيء
نخرج فيه كمجموعة أقوى
اليوم
بعد إعلان
[موسيقى]
سيكون هناك سيدي الذين
سيقترحون أن اتفاق اليوم
كسرها كما كان من قبل جاريد
كوشنر هو إصلاح تجميلي من
قبل الرياض والآخرين قبل إدارة بايدن الجديدة هذه
والتي
بصراحة أوضحت أنها تبحث
لإعادة التقييم.  علاقتها مع
المملكة العربية السعودية ولكي تكون لها
علاقة أفضل
مع إيران للمضي قدمًا ، ماذا
تقول لأولئك الذين يقترحون أن هذا
إصلاح تجميلي لورقة تين كما كانت من
قبل المملكة جيدًا أعتقد
أن أول شيء يجب قوله هو
أن الأولوية في إعلان ألوها
هي نحن دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وأعتقد أن أول
شيء
هو محاولة رأب الصدع
داخل نفس المنظمة داخل
نفس
مجموعة البلدان التي تشترك في
أه تعلم أن التاريخ يشترك في الكثير من
العلاقات الأسرية وما إلى ذلك
وهكذا دواليك وما إلى ذلك ، لذا أود أن
أقول
إن التركيز الرئيسي لرأب هذا
الصدع هو تركيز داخلي في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ،
لكنني وقد استغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً وسأقول
إن  جميع جهود المجتمع في
الوصول
إلى ترتيب اليوم أه
تعلمون أن تمثيلنا ودول أخرى
لم يكن شيئًا تم القيام به في
أسابيع
، لقد استغرق حقًا فترة طويلة من
الوقت حتى نصل
إلى هذه النقطة ، لذا فإن حجتي ستكون
أن أي تركيزات خارجية
أخرى ثانوية ،
لكنني أعتقد أن
التركيز
الرئيسي للتفاؤل الذي نراه
اليوم هو إلى حد كبير قراءة دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
للمكان الذي يجب أن نكون فيه
ما يجب أن نركز عليه على
مدى صعوبة المنطقة وكيف
نتعامل  مع هذا
الموضوع الآن هل هذا تجميلي أم لا
علينا أن نعمل في صنع هذه الصفقة
أه تعلم أه أه
تمامًا أه مقاوم ومن نواح كثيرة
وأه يتحدث نيابة عن الإمارات
لدينا كل
النية لضمان أن إعلان الألوة
هو نجاح لأننا نشعر
أنه في مصلحة
الإمارات ونشعر
أنه في مصلحة المنطقة